frankly as an insurance company a lot of
times it's really hard to know what's
going on
under the hood
so our pitch is to deliver a platform
that really helps with data
to solve these three pillars uh and on
by using that will also create a great
customer experience to the insured at
the other side of things to um
to help them you know fix their problem
as fast as possible and on the best way
possible
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an in media
partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be talking to michael crickely
co-founder and cto of five sigma an
ensure tech company helping insurers
optimize claims handling processes
through data previously michael was
leading r d teams within the prime
minister's office he worked on multiple
ground-breaking projects including one
that has received the israel defense
prize michael is a data science and math
enthusiast with a bsc and msc
mathematics from barulan university
hey
michael crescelli welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you great michael uh two
michaels at the same call this is great
uh two michael's on the same call
exactly i'm really really excited to
talk to you about your own journey
and
and what you're doing today is
co-founder and cto of five sigma
you've had some pretty great
announcements over the last few weeks
with some exciting funding grounds to
continue on your mission and i'm always
curious about people's journeys and you
know with the background primarily
mathematics all the way to now working
in the claims industries and free to be
sas i'm excited to to hear a little bit
about that and your entrance to this
world and you also serve in the prime
minister's office you a recipient
amongst others on your team for the
israel defense prize and
which i was also honored to be a part of
a couple years back in my own service so
so to michael's and we share some other
things and and i know how meaningful
that is as well so yeah i can't wait to
hear about you know your the great work
that you're doing tell me a little bit
about you about you know your interests
and and how you perceive sort of your
entrepreneurial journey
well i was always an interested guy at
tons of things uh and i was always kind
of a geek
and i really started as uh
as a math geek uh
so math was really
was really my thing
when i was growing up so
you know frankly like computers i didn't
really care about or didn't like
i wasn't one of these geeks that had uh
broken computers in their garages i was
like solving equations and what i i used
to do um and then
somewhere i did my
bachelor's degree uh during my high
school days and then uh the prime
minister's office opportunity uh came
into play as my role uh in the army and
really there is where i
i dived into
uh software right this is what this was
really uh where i learned um software
but
what we actually learned there is not
even
software necessarily but how to use
technology to solve operational problems
that's like
and this was the greatest school ever i
think that i think it was uh an amazing
pressure cooker for
19 year old
a guy from uh from batiana was like uh
most of my days overwhelmed um wow and
um
but but the thing is like you get used
to it right so then when someone comes
and say hey please solve this impossible
problem
you need to do that by the end of this
month and it has to work
uh you kind of get used to it so this
was kind of the rhythm of um
of how uh how our things uh went there
uh and i think that a lot of what i'm
doing now and a lot of what we're doing
with five sigma is bringing that
mentality of
finding an operational problem
being geeks and like loving technology
and mapping technology to solve these
operational problems and i think that
this is the best way to do things in the
world uh a lot of
you know a lot of things are coming from
just tech uh and we were really wanted
to dive into learn a world that we knew
nothing about like insurance claims uh
like i didn't even know that something
like that exists
then you know a few years later
come and say hey
you know you're doing it a little bit
wrong let's do it better together
this is the like the best um
i think the best way to describe
entrepreneurs right just
deep dive into a problem sometimes you
know something about it many times you
don't and just use everything you know
and uh and your
skills to do something about it you know
i love it i i love the mentality i
couldn't agree more about the experience
and both you know the entrance to it and
the overwhelming nature of it but also
getting used to it
and not making it a part of just the
school but maybe making it a part of the
mentality of who we are and how we think
through problems and following with the
excitement of diving into something you
know literally nothing about and and
often i think a lot of people agree that
they're real ingenuity comes from those
that don't know about the industry and
are coming to
with with fresh new eyes tell me a
little bit about it about insurance
claims and how you perceived the problem
that you're then solving with five sigma
yeah sure so
and um
we can talk about the journey we had uh
different words for it but now we can uh
articulate it uh
uh very crisp i think that uh we are
solving a problem that's close
that is called claims leakage claims
leakage is basically uh the difference
between
this process the optimal process of
handling claims uh right so how would
you want to handle claims as an
insurance company or as a user or as you
know uh a broker or as someone that's
part of this journey which is very
complicated across multiple uh vendors
and uh what's going on today in the
world right what's the real uh
the reality of handling claims nowadays
um and there's a huge gap between these
two um and this gap is called uh well
the financial problem of this is called
claims leakage um and i think that as
everything in insurance this is a huge
problem to solve
right it is estimated at around 100
billion dollars a year in the us only
wow uh so this is our playground right
this is the value that can be created um
and then
our our thesis is that a lot of what the
the problems are not really about
bad mentality or you know bad employees
or people uh but rather uh outdated
technology at the core right and our ph
is that we can create a
a core system a core claim system um
that's uh based on data and that
leverages data in three main ways one is
automating away a lot of stuff
uh that no one needs to take care of the
other is helping with decision-making
because there's so many decisions to be
made throughout this process and then
lastly
showing everyone what's going on in the
organization right this is
the centerpiece of
where your exposures are and where you
your entire payout essentially is and
where um
your risks are and frankly as an
insurance company a lot of times it's
really hard to know what's going on uh
under the hood
so our pitch is to deliver a platform
that really helps with data uh to solve
these three uh pillars uh and on
by using that we also create a great
customer experience to the insured uh at
the other side of thing to um
to help them you know fix their problem
as fast as possible and on the best way
possible
what what are some of the challenges
associated with this so obviously
anytime anybody wants to tackle a
hundred billion dollar market gap
and and anything that has to do with
regulations let alone insurance a lot of
challenges arise what are some of those
challenges
yeah i think that um
the challenges are uh are varied right
so insurance tech uh the technology
right now in or in older insurance
companies right there are
a lot of already deployed systems uh and
there's a lot of ecosystem around these
systems so
looking into hey i'm gonna replace your
claim software uh a lot of
a lot of both on the i.t side and the
claim side really look at that and say
oh my god but this is like the heart of
my operation what are you talking about
uh but you know
right now insurtecus is of course a huge
deal uh across the world right company
great companies like lemonade and hippo
and roots that they're created
essentially a new way
of insurance and with
an entirely um
an entirely new stack
uh now
other companies say oh okay so a it's
possible and me i need to do something
about it
and i need to do something about it from
the core
and this is where we come in and say
hey
this is the way to go right we can do it
fast we can do it in a sas way an
iterative way and we can create so much
value um
during that process and i always tell
everyone is that we
uh we did a lot and we're just getting
started right so
this hundred billion dollar problem uh
is not solved yet um
but um
we're really excited on exploring more
and more of it you know
right now
five sigma very quickly where does that
the name come from does it have a
meaning with with what you're doing
yeah
not really uh okay basically it comes
from uh
it comes from
high uh high certainty in physics uh
and we were five founders when we
started uh so you know it was a long
discussion that ended up with five sigma
uh which was um
which was great and uh in
when we began we really wanted to
uh we're kind of looking for we're
really passionate about data so we're
looking at problems that uh data can
help with right so data and data science
can help with
and then
studying this industry we said oh
five sigma sounds uh
uh
sounds academic enough
so it kind of worked for us
right i think that you know the the
whole concept
of
of tackling a poem like you're tackling
is something that you know makes me
excited as a you know as a future
entrepreneur something that you know
just you know i can feel the energy
resonating from you and then how you're
excited about just not not even you know
the financial aspects of it or but but
just the impact that you can have on
such a huge problem that you're facing i
think it's i think it's really
incredible now as your
you know cto of a rising startup that is
growing quickly and with some incredible
investors and incredible partners
what is how is your role shaping in your
eyes how is your role transitioning you
know from just co-founding the startup
up until now and how do you prepare
yourself for what's to come
wow that's a great question and i think
that
you know startup
companies are
as you
look at them throughout their timelines
right they are just different companies
they have the same kind of vision uh and
there is the same goal but you know
when we started off
on the couch in my living room we were
very different than uh a year ago and
now we're kind of building towards the
right so how is the organization gonna
look like and i think that what really
what's really unique about founders is
that they cannot do what's needed right
so they just
pick things from the floor and say all
right so we don't have that let's some
someone do something about it
and we had a lot of that um
when we started and uh you know i was
always very on the tech side on one hand
but also very customer facing
uh and i still am i i really like to do
demos i like to talk to customers i
really like to get their feedback um and
then you know say all right so you know
we started off with this is the vibe
that i'm getting you know we had
nothing but no this is feelings that i'm
getting from from our calls and now
we're really in a place where uh we're
growing as an organization and we are um
hiring um
hiring everything basically uh but then
uh this is where we kind of wanna build
an organization that scales and
my job really changes towards the right
you're you're basically need to manage
manage that team and rather than just
doing demos uh i will definitely do some
of them uh but that will not be my main
role anymore you know
obviously your work now is is quite
different from the work you did in the
prime minister's office and before that
where you know where do you find your
own inspiration or or your own
excitement within what you're doing what
what is it about your day to day
that really gets you up in the morning
and you know makes you so excited about
what you're doing
i think it really boils down to the team
that you're working with the day-to-day
i think is 100 the team uh
whether you're working on
uh
uh something that you know that sucks or
you're working on the most exciting uh
task in the world uh if you have your
co-workers and uh
that you love you know
working with drinking coffee with
drinking beer after work with i think
that this is the excitement that comes
along with all right so everything that
we're doing um
really
comes with a lot of learning because i'm
a first-time entrepreneur so like i
always say to everyone i'm a co-founder
the first time basically i'm doing
everything and i know nothing
so
i'm always kind of learning you know so
i always learn and learn new things
about myself and about the company and
about you know what we're trying to do
what we're trying to achieve this is
exciting for me
now if you go back a little bit you know
before the army before five sigma
obviously
you know who who are you as a person
who's michael as a person
you know what are you really curious
about what drives your fascination on
the day today
yeah i i think that
i really love
challenges i really love to do
hard things and uh this was this came to
math when i was a kid and it came to
uh you know i was playing the piano uh
for a while so uh i only pushed myself
really hard to do better and better at
everything right whether it's piano or
sports or uh or math
um and i was always kind of
running towards a challenge
and
and this is i think how i saw things um
and i was really a geek so you know
i really like solving uh solving
problems and learning things um all the
time did you know that entrepreneurship
is gonna be your route or that creating
a company is going to be a route because
you know i i also know a lot of people
that are you know they're engineers
they're mathematicians being an
entrepreneur and being a co-founder
isn't you know their top priority
they're more excited to be you know in
the in the weeds and the needles and and
actually going and being mostly hands-on
yeah frankly i had no idea if you if you
would tell me that i'm gonna be an
entrepreneur i would laugh at you
probably like i don't know seven years
ago we kind of wow i kind of stumbled
into it you know i was just one day i
was at my couch with uh a great group of
people and we said can i all right let's
do something you know and um
and then it came
everything came after that uh
what's the most surprising thing that
you learned you know about this journey
that that perhaps you didn't know back
then that maybe you know me or my
friends don't know yet before we go on
our own journey
yeah i think that
a lot of what i've learned is the power
of community there's a huge community of
entrepreneurs uh
everywhere but in tel aviv uh especially
and uh now what you're doing and hearing
these stories and then uh talking to
people that were uh there can really do
two things one is help you with making
decisions but even more importantly help
you not feel
uh stupid and not feel alone and not
feel a failure uh which is especially in
the beginning it's kind of if you don't
talk to anyone it really stands this way
all the time you know
100 100 percent uh i and i think that
you know the the journey is an exciting
one and i can and i have to say that one
thing that i just i get energized with
this conversation it's it's the way that
you perceive it empty and sort of the
excitement that you bring with it
because obviously you know there's a ton
of issues and a ton of problems that
everybody faces
from hr to the you know the team that is
the most important to the actual
technology and the problem but the exam
with which you bring with it is just
exciting now if i were to ask any of
your co-founders employees investors who
michael really is what are some words
that would come to mind
um i think that they will say that um
i'm kind of interested in doing
a lot of things so i'm really not like
all right i'm gonna be the best
developer out there so you know i'll do
marketing one day and sales one day and
this kind of thing uh
hopefully they'll say it all nice i hope
and uh and i think that they also say
that i'm
always like a pusher so i'm pushing
forward uh and i also
i guess that i'm also kind of calm uh
sometimes i can't see that
yeah sometimes too much
and there's a good balance between us
in the group you know to wake me up
sometimes
when you need to go wake up you know
wonderful michael thank you very very
much this was so enjoyable best of luck
with five sigma solving a very very
important issue
and i'm excited to see where where the
company is headed and thank you for
sharing this time with me i really
appreciate it thank you so much michael
i had so much fun
thank you
[Music]